[Music]
babies cry all the time whether you like
it or not and it takes a very patient
parent to make them stop when it comes
to TV and movies however a director may
actually want a baby to cry on command
and this requires hiring someone with a
special set of skills
[Laughter]
that's Elaine hall she's what's known in
Hollywood as a baby Wrangler a baby
Wrangler is a interpreter between what
the director wants a young child to do
and front of a camera she's worked with
infants and young children on a variety
of commercials TV shows and movies like
The Flintstones grace under fire and
Akeelah and the bee so first off where
do these crying babies come from babies
just like adult actors come from casting
calls but they're only legally allowed
to work for four hours a day on set so
there's a simple trick used to extend
their camera time very often when you
see a TV show or a film twins are used
to play one role there's also a few
other rules in place when using young
actors for every set that has a child
there's a studio teacher on the set for
infants there must be a studio teacher
and a nurse for non crying scenes
working with babies and young children
involves making it fun for them
everything was made into a game I would
put on the lens of the camera
funny faces on the lens when they needed
to make direct eye contact I would be
behind the camera in every scene making
them laugh but for crying it's a whole
different story
Elaine uses a special technique what I
do to get babies to cry as I start to
cry myself for example I'll go
[Music]
[Applause]
and a baby will start to cry when a baby
even an infant
here's another baby cry the infant or
the baby will start to cry themselves
this is an example of empathy it's
pretty instantaneous she used this
technique in Akeelah and the bee in this
scene Akeelah sister brings her baby to
the event and it starts to cry and her
technique has never failed so far my
success rate is a hundred percent
she says she's heard of other baby
Wranglers using questionable techniques
like placing bad odors in front of the
child or making a loud noise but
according to Elaine these sorts of
methods may be harmful to the child and
should be avoided if the baby's face
doesn't need to be shown on camera
oftentimes they'll use a doll instead so
once it's crying how do you get the baby
to stop when I stop crying and then I'll
look at the baby and assure the baby
that everything's safe I'm okay she's
okay then very quickly a baby will stop
she may also use rattles and bells to
help if necessary regardless of the
scene Elaine says it's important that
the baby spend time with the actor ahead
of time I always create have the actor
and the baby create relationship
off-camera so that it's not like you're
just plopping a kid into a stranger's
lap
as you may have an opportunity to
compete for any remaining places Kiana
get that baby out of here